سننهض ونحن اقواه يقول الاتراك فالكوارث
والمحن لا توقفوا الحياه
تقف على عتاب استحقاقات سياسيه حاسمه لم
ترى السلطات داعيا لارجائها
هناك مغرضون يفرحون لرؤيه ما اسفرت عنه
الزلازل ظنا منهم ان الحكومه والدوله
والشعبه سيقعون تحت هذه الانقاض لكن على
هؤلاء الذين لم يذهبوا لمنطقه الزلازل ولم
يزوروا المنكوبين ان يعلموا ان الشعب
التركي سيرد على هؤلاء المغريطين في
الرابع عشر من مايو ايار المقبل قاده
احزاب المعارضه التي تبحث اسماء منافسين
محتملين للرئيس اردوغان سارعت بالفعل الى
التشكيك في كفاءه حكومته لاداره الكارثه
ومن باب النقد نفسه تجد حماسه في هذا
المعسكر للاحتكام الى الصندوق في الاجال
المحدده
حان وقت ذهبي للانتخابات حان الوقت لاسقاط
الحسابات الشخصيه وعمل ما يلزم لخدمه
الامه والشعب لقد دمرت الحكومه كل
المؤسسات والمنظمات وحرفتها عن هدفها الذي
انشئت من اجله بعد مئه عام نرى مره اخرى
ان وحده وسلامه الوطن في خطر
لطالما اطلقت الكوارث الطبيعيه تداعيات
سياسيه اعلى الاستقطابات على حساب الوحده
يعتقد الرئيس اردوغان ان الاتهامات
بالتقصير في التعامل مع زلزال كهرمان مراش
وتوابعه تحركها دوافع سياسيه طلب الرجل
الصفحه عما سجل من تاخير في الايام الاولى
في تنظيم عمليات الاغاثه وتعهد بمحاسبه
جميع المقصرين قضائيا واداريا وسياسيا
لكن ذلك لا يزيح كل اللغط الذي يحيط
بانتخابات لن تجرى في الظروف نفسها التي
شهدها اختراع عام 2018
سيكون التصويت نفسه تحديا في المحافظات
العشر الاكثر تضررا بالزلزال والخاضعه
لحاله طوارئ هناك يقتل نحو اربعه عشر
مليون شخص ما زال معظمهم يلملم جراحه
فمنهم من فقد الاحبه والماوى ومنهم من
يحتاج كهؤلاء الصغار بدعم نفسي كي يستوعب
ما جرى